اكيد تنضم لنا من ماسك مراسلت الجزيره
رانيا تريدي كما ينضم الينا من كرامات
تورس مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج نبدا معك
عمر وهذه الموجه الجديده ويترقب ايضا ان
تستمر هذه العمليات الموجهه الى مناطق عده
في اوكرانيا
نعم عبد السلام وفقا لتقارير سابقه لهيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه كانت دائما تتحدث عن
موجه استهداف واسعه تشنها القوات الروسيه
كلها سبعه او 10 ايام
منذ منذ فتره منذ اعلان الحاق بعض
المقاطعات التي سيطرت عليها القوات
الروسيه همم الفيدراليه الروسيه عن منذ
شهر اكتوبر برج
الايام التي يكون فيها التصعيد ليس فقط في
العاصمه والمحافظات المقاطات الغربيه
والجنوب بل ايضا هنا في الوسط وفي الجهه
الشرقيه كان هناك تصعيد ملحوظ منذ يومين
على الاقل المدن والبلدات الكبرى همم في
اقليم
خاضعه لسيطره القوات الاوكرانيه اضافه الى
مقاطع
همم كبير من قبل القوات الروسيه على سبيل
المثال مدينه الكرامه
الرئيسيه الاخرى
اضافه الى
تتعارضت لقصف وهي غارقه بالظلام منذ يوم
امس حتى قبل ساعات استطاعت السلطات
الاوكرانيه ان تستعيد الكهرباء اضافه الى
المياه وذلك ان القذف الروسي استهدف محطات
ضخ المياه اضافه لتوليد الطاقه وكان هناك
انقطاع كبير في شبكه الاتصالات في المناطق
المذكوره كذلك الامر هناك عوده للمسيرات
الاوكرانيه الايرانيه في مدينه دنيبر وكما
قال حاكم المقاطعه بان هناك العديد من
طائرات شاهد من تراث شاهد الاوكرانيه
استهدفت بعض البلدات في مدينه الجنوبيه
وتحديدا القريبه منها من مقاطعه زباريجيا
كما ذكرت كان هناك قصف كبير على مدن الشرق
وتحديدا في مدينه
42 شخصا جرحه نتيجه قصف روسي احد المدارس
التي كانت تتخذ كما كان للاجئين من مناطق
شهد من منطقه شهدت اقترابا للقتال اليوم
كنا برفقه الجيش الاوكراني تحديدا في
محوري باخمه الان القوات الروسيه تحاول ان
توسع
النطاقال
بالاضافه الى مدينه باهمد فان هناك
محاولات للاشغال لاشغال القوات الاوكرانيه
عند التق- عبر التقدم الى مدينه سيردار
القريبه منها ولكن السلطات الاوكرانيه
والجيش الاوكراني قال ان هناك ان الوضع
تحت السيطره وان القوات الاوكرانيه ما
تزال تتمكن من صد هذه
الهجامات الروسيه المستمره على هذا المحور
ايضا على المحاور في لوهانسكو ايضا في
محوري
وربما هذا التطور اللافت هو الذي همم جاء
بتصريح من حاكم المقاطعه مقاطعه سارته
الروسيه همم باستهداف ما سماها هو اهدافا
مجهوله في منطقه انجلش
[تصفيق]
اه في واقع الامر يعني الامر يمكن القول
عبد السلام ليس جديدا فيما يتعلق باستهداف
قاعده انجلش التي تضم طائرات
استراتيجيه روسيه نحن نعلم ان القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه قبل الحادث حادث اليوم
كانت قد استهدفت القاعده مرتين قبل نحوي
اسبوع بمسيرات وايضا في شهر اكتوبر الماضي
حيث يعني تم اسقاط وسيارات اوكرانيه وذلك
الحدث في اكتوبر على وجه التحديد تسبب
سقوط قتلى وجرح في صفوف القوات الروسيه
العامله في المطار اليوم بالفعل تم اعلان
ان ااه يعني انه تم اعتراض اهداف مجهوله
يعني لم يتم تحديدها من قبل الحاكم
المقاطعه ولكن كما قلت هذا الحادث هو حادث
مكرر همم من جهه اخرى لو تحدثنا عن تطورات
الوضع الميداني همم جانب الروسي يؤكد ان
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه مستمره خلال
اليوم الماضي بحسب تصريحات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تم القضاء على
200 عسكري اوكرانيا في مختلف الجبهات
العمليات القتاليه بحسب وزاره الدفاع تركز
بالدراجه الاولى على مناطق همم محور
كبيانس في خارطه على محور كراس نديمان في
همم وجانس بالاضافه الى دانيس وعلى واجهه
التحديد في دانيسك اشارت وزاره الدفاع ان
القوات المسلحه الروسيه تقوم بشان هجمات
على هذا المحور ضد المواقع القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه اود الاشاره لانه وفقا
للتصريحات الرسميه الصادره من قبل همم
الهيئات المحليه في كل من القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه يعني تركز بقصدها للاحياء يعني
السكنيه في هذه المناطق في منطقه على سبيل
المثال عبد السلام سلطات تتحدث عن ان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه استهدفت سته
احياء سكنيه يعني 50 مره بنحو 200 قديه
فما تسبب بمقتل امراه اصابه عدد من
المدنيين الاخرين همم بجروح هذا من جهه
اخرى وعلى الصعيد يعني السياسيه لو تحدثنا
على ما يبدو كل الحديث الذي يدور في الغرب
حاليا فيما يتعلق بمبادره الرئيس
الاوكراني خطه السلام للرئيس الاوكراني
ميرسي يعني هذه الخطه يمكن القول انها
تزيد من الفجوه ما بين روسيا من اوكرانيا
مدعومه بالدول الغربيه من جهه اخرى اليوم
لابروف حرفيا قال ان هذه الخطه انطلاقا من
البنود التي تضمها تدل على ان الجانب
الاوكرانيين ليس مهتم بالحوار واشار الى
روسيا لن تتفاوض مع اي طرف كان فيما يتعلق
بهذه همم الخطه خطه السلامه التي اقترحها
التي تؤكد وتشير على ضروره سحب القوات
الروسيه بما في ذلك من تلك المناطق
الاربعه التي كانت روسيا قدمتها الى
اراضيها ونحن العالم ان الرئيس
كريم لان الدفاع الخارجيه اكدت انه لا
يمكن عقد اي مفاوضات بشان التسويه
اوكرانيه في اوكرانيا ما لم يتم الاخ في
عين الاعتبار تطورات الاوضاع على الارض
هذه الخطه ايضا لقيته اليوم انتقادات
كبيره من قبل الناطق باسم الخارجيه ماريا
زخاربه التي وصفتها بالجنونيه وسخيفه
اشارت الا ان اا يعني هذه الخطه هي محاوله
من قبل الولايات المتحده لتقديم اوكرانيا
على انها دوله
تحاول صنع السلام حسب تعبيرها واشارت الا
ان همم يعني هذه الخطه هي تاتي في اطار
المحاولات محاولات شرعنه ما تمته ووصفته
ماريه خربت يعني همم
يعني بالفراغ الذي لا يعني شيء حسب
تعبيرها لنتابع ما قالته على وجه التحديد
فيما يتعلق بهذه الجزئيه
الحديث يدور عن عقد قمه للسلام في الامم
المتحده في الذكرى السنويه لانطلاق
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه والتي لابد لها
ووفقا لسلطات كيف ان تسهم في تنفيذ
الافكار الغريبه للرئيس سيلنسكي التي قام
ببلورتها في اطار ما يسمى بخطه السلام هذه
افكار جنونيه وسخيفه مشاركه روسيا في هذه
القمه مشروط باستلامها الكامل وغير
المشروط لا يمكن تفسير ذلك الا بان كيف لم
تعد تملك القوه في مثل هذه الظروف لا يمكن
الحديث عن اي مبادرات جديه من قبل كيف
ومواليها الغربيين
بتقول ايه شكرا لكم